es ist sommer die leute sind gut drauf
reden wir also über den tod
[Musik]
die moderne stellt einen vor viele
herausforderungen logische folge
überforderung verzweiflung und ängste
und damit nicht genug viele sind gerade
auch in ihrer angst überfordert wie soll
ich denn jetzt angst haben vom russen
von terroristen oder frommholz viele
menschen entscheiden sich dafür angst
vor terror zu haben es hilft ein blick
in mord statistiken zu werfen um
herauszufinden von wem die eigentliche
gefahr ausgeht
die meisten menschen werden ja gar nicht
von terroristen ermordet sondern von
ihren eigenen bekannten das ist die gute
nachricht
die allerwenigsten menschen werden
überhaupt umgebracht aber wenn man
umgebracht wurde
dann könnte man den mörder meisten schon
fast ein drittel aller morde sind
beziehungstaten falls sie sich dass
gerade als heterosexuelles paar angucken
und nervös werden kleiner tipp
wahrscheinlich ist der mann der täter
der aufklärer sagt habt keine angst vor
fremden hat lieber angst vor ihrer
eigenen familie
vor einigen jahren gab es eine spannende
meldung aus den usa
da hieß es dann dass in den jahren zuvor
mehr menschen durch herabfallenden
fernseher umgekommen waren als durch
terroristen
ich glaube mittlerweile es ist völlig
egal welche sterbe art man sich ausdenkt
es macht auf jeden fall jedes jahr ein
amerikaner mit
als ich das mit den herabfallenden
fernseher angehört habe haben sich mir
sofort drei fragen aufgedrängt erstens
wer ist der anführer der fernseher
zweitens kann man ihn töten und drittens
was ist eigentlich die rolle der
geheimdienste
fast 10.000 menschen sind 2015 in
deutschland bei unfällen im haushalt
gestorben
80 prozent davon durch hinfallen wie
spektakulär ist das auf ein mordopfer
kommen in deutschland 20 leute die sich
sagen ich lasse mich nicht umbringen ich
will einfach so in meiner wohnung um und
dann bin ich tot
teppiche und staubsauger kabel haben
mehr kriminelle energie als man ihnen
zutraut
man muss keine angst haben raus zu gehen
man muss angst davor haben drinnen zu
bleiben
gut beim rausgehen kann man zum beispiel
erfahren werden einigen wir uns auf den
kompromiss aktivität des einfach immer
gefährlich islamistischer terrorismus
ist nicht lustig er sollte mit allen
demokratischen mitteln des rechtsstaats
bekämpft werden aber warum macht niemand
was gegen treppen während in deutschland
in den letzten zehn jahren 16 menschen
durch islamistischen terror umgekommen
sind sind im gleichen zeitraum über
10.000 menschen beim treppensteigen
gestorben
das war übrigens grad der treppenwitz
dieser geschichte wäre jährlich über
1000 menschen von treppen ermordet
werden bringen aufzüge im jahr keine
zehn menschen um
und wovor haben menschen angst vor
aufzügen die indizien mehren sich
langsam dass angst nichts rational es
ist die leiter eine besonders
hinterhältige form der treppe bringt
jährlich über 100 leuten den tod wir
brauchen nicht strengere anti terror
maßnahmen sondern strengere anti leiter
maßnahmen und ich glaube der
strategische fehler liegt darin an den
flughäfen alle leitern und kontrolliert
ins land einreisen zu lassen
sogar babys sind in den usa übrigens
gefährlicher als terroristen
2015 sind 30 amerikaner von kleinen
kindern unter sechs jahren erschossen
worden
klar wenn so viele geladene waffen
herumliegen ist es nur eine frage der
zeit bis irgendwann mal ein kleinkind
gegen den abzug krabbelt und auch hier
sagt der aufklärer wieder habt keine
angst vor
liebe angst vor ihrer eigenen familie
im zweifelsfall es ist das baby